la plaza frente al ministerio de asuntos
exteriores español se ha quedado pequeña
para la cantidad de personas que ha
venido a manifestarse en contra de la
decisión del gobierno de pedro sánchez
con respecto a la posición sobre el
sáhara occidental tienen un mensaje muy
claro es un mensaje bien corto sánchez
no tienen derecho de dividir por el
pueblo saharaui a la autodeterminación
no a la autonomía como fátima hay tantas
personas que están aquí incluso personas
nacidas en campos de refugiados en
argelia como por salma saharaui de
corazón como ya nos decía cuál es tu
mensaje cómo te sientes a ver cómo has
dicho yo por supuesto soy saharaui pero
también soy argelina de nacimiento
por obligación y soy española de
nacionalidad y yo lo que he presenciado
muchas habrá presencia dos generaciones
antes que yo en un mes
la venta por segunda vez del sáhara
occidental' trafican con los derechos
humanos y nos hacen ver que no yo he
tenido que ver desde pequeña como muchos
otros niños la doble cara de la moneda y
preguntarme por qué yo merezco este
trato porque yo que el hecho ya este
mundo para que me trate así yo siempre
he pensado y lo sigo pensando que el
sáhara es para los suyos los que
nacieron en ella lucharon por ella y
dieron la vida por su libertad es para
esos que nunca se rindieron para
conseguir sus partes para los que
lucharon lucha habilitarán una y mil
veces más nada libre
como ella y como salma también españoles
son nacidos en españa y también quieren
demostrar que la postura perdón que la
postura del gobierno de españa no es la
del pueblo español
por parte del sánchez es una humillación
para el pueblo español porque en sáhara
es español y los saharahuis son nuestros
hermanos como en una decisión política
que ha levantado mucha polémica en
españa y que seguirá levantando polémica
hasta que el gobierno de pedro sánchez
decida hacia atrás este cambio de color
tenemos ahora mismo el ring